we've already talked a lot about plate
boundaries where essentially new crust
material is being created and the plates
and the plates are actually moving apart
we call these divergent boundaries in
the example we showed of this was the
the mid-atlantic ridge where essentially
new crustal material is being created
now on the other side of the equation
you have areas where plates are ramming
into each other we see that over here
where the Nazca plate is running into
the South American plate we see it over
here where the Pacific plate is running
into is running into the Filipino plate
they're running into each other
so what happens over there so what we're
going to do is just go through the
different scenarios the general idea is
that one plate is going to get subducted
under another their ramming into each
other one is going to get essentially
pushed under the other one this diagram
shows some subduction over here this is
a essentially oceanic plate being
subducted under another oceanic plate so
not too different than what might happen
where the pacific plate runs into the
filipino plate right over here and then
on this side of the diagram we see an
oceanic plate and the oceanic crust
getting subducted under a continental
plate right over here and this is what's
happening and when the Nazca plate is
getting subducted under the South
American plate and when that happens a
couple of things so you have the oceanic
plate being pushed under and what
happens at the same time the continental
plate gets pushed upwards causing
mountain ranges like the Andes and
that's exactly what causes what has
created the Andes it's that upward force
from the from the Nazca plate being
pushed under the South American plate at
that coastline and what you're also
going to see is and you can imagine you
have these huge plates grinding past
each other and it's not a very smooth
process every now and then you kind of
reach a breaking point in huge amounts
of energy and huge amounts of energy get
released so you're also going to see a
lot of earthquakes in those areas and
you could and we know that Chile has a
lot of earthquakes and then on top of
that this is going to result in a lot of
heat in a lot of the friction of the
plates grinding
past each other essentially allowing
magma to form at that part of of the of
the rocket because it's getting so
heated and so you'll also have volcanoes
in these areas where essentially
something is being subducted underneath
a continental plate now we also talked
about what's happening in the Pacific
where we have the Pacific plate being
subducted under the filipino plate
that's what we kept keep referring to
over here and that's doing a couple of
interesting things whenever you have
subduction you have trenches but it's
most interesting or at least in my mind
the deepest trenches have been created
where you have an oceanic plate being
subducted under another oceanic plate so
a couple of things are going to happen
you're going to have a very deep you're
going to have trenches form you're going
to have a trench form over here we see
in this diagram we also have a trench in
the first example but you have trenches
formed where the oceanic where one
oceanic plate is being subducted under
another and then you have that same type
of friction that you saw over here
create volcanoes and those volcanoes
will initially be underwater volcanoes
since these are both oceanic plates or
they were kind of we're dealing with
oceanic crust at that point of the plate
it doesn't have to be an entirely an
oceanic plate and they'll first be
underwater volcanoes but as the lava
piles up and hardens it'll eventually
turn into a group of islands and we have
that happening where the Pacific plate
runs into the filipino plate and first
we have the trench so let me just draw
everything right here so this is the
boundary roughly roughly speaking this
is the boundary between the two plates
this is the Pacific plate and this is
the Filipino plate right over here and
so where it's being subducted you have
the Mariana Trench which is the deepest
trench in the world
it goes down 11 it goes down 11
kilometers 11,000 meters that's deeper
than Mount Everest is high Mount Everest
is about 9,000 meters high and we'll see
that's also due to another convergent
plate boundary another place where
plates are running into each other so
not only do you see the mariana trench
here because one plate is being
subducted under the other you see the
formation of the mariana islands which
are essentially created from underwater
volcanoes because of all of the enter
being released and this is actually a
depiction of what's the subduction
that's happening at the Mariana Trench
you have this subduction over here and
then you have the Mariana Islands being
created by essentially the energy
causing a magma and lava essentially
magma before it surfaces to flow to the
top and as lava it just goes and starts
building these islands now the last type
of convergent boundary is when you have
to two parts of continental crust
running into each other so that's the
situation that we have in where the
Indian plate is running into the
eurasian plate and i think you might
already guess what's going to happen
there when you have two pieces of
continental crust running into each
other one isn't more or less dense than
the other and so at least the crustal
portions of them the crustal portions of
them are just going to keep are just
going to keep jamming into each other
and so they're just going to push things
up where this is a depiction right here
that I got from the USGS
now what step what's what's kind of
depicting is this is the Indian plate
this is Eurasian Plate this is if you if
you rewind a good bit before they've
really had a chance to jam into each
other but as they're jamming into each
other the Indian plate is kind of
digging in a little bit not being fully
subducted and it's causing the land to
rise and what that essentially ends up
with is you end up with something like
you end up with something like the
Himalayas and this right here is a
picture of Mount Everest which is almost
9,000 meters high 9,000 meters above sea
level so it's almost as high as the
Mariana Trench is deep